Hello everybody my name is markiplier and welcome back to sleeping dawn. I've got Wade here say hi Wade
Hey guys, and we're gonna get through this game. Hey guys welcome back to sleeping Dom with Mark. What's up, dude?
Hi alright, so how do you do this? I?
Have no idea, but I guess we just start Gabe and hope for the best sure okay alright
I'm ready see when I was playing it before it was scary very much scary yes
But I didn't get to a single switch, and I didn't quite understand the full mechanics of everything about that I get
Things I have learned
Yes, you want to be quiet around the guys on the walls if they jumped on you dick
There's the shadow ones you have to shine a flashlight on that if you shine it enough they die
There's um like gape keeper wizard looking guys
Are near the levers if you see the wizard II guys you're near pal ever okay
If you see that weird witchy left 4 dead lady throw rocks before she gets mad and the rocks can distract her right, okay?
So what thing do you want, or do we all get a thing?
So we get to each since there's two of us. I've got a rod
I've got the rocks right now alright wait hang on. Where are you? Where'd you go?
Dude, do me a favor real quick bend it like look straight up
Okay, ah damn it. I was hoping like you were gonna rotate to the waist like in Bigfoot. Just like
Arch broke it back. Yeah, hopefully they've got chalking rocks. All right. I've got sticking light
light and stick art certain reason not to have the light is there a reason not to I
Don't think so not that I've figured out. I've only I've only run a few rounds over in the garden JP alright well
Let's do this for realsies, and hopefully uh
After me excuse me yes
You do is there any reason not to run
um it's good to have stealing but I
So for these big stats you guys. I never really knew what triggered them I?
Thought was getting close
Some do some don't Oh
Some of them come after yeah some do some don't I don't like that about that that ain't no good you notice
We've not had any turns you have just been funneling us and directs you. Oh, you know
Your choice nice little chalky X down here. Uh-huh. Okay? Well we got a lot of archways
Huh
Mark Crouch crouch you stupid idiot a Crouch annex there he sees Crouch. I'm pressing control the crowd God
You look so stupid when you're crouching the big dumb idiot
It's too dark to whap alright you wanna, go this way alright which way sniff-sniff with your nose. Okay. Thank you
Oh, thank you. I don't know why you got creepy Wade. This is a very dead end
Yeah
We should go this. Okay, looks like this one. Also dead end. Yeah, we should go alright cool glad
We closed down this whole Avenue was a trap. Yeah
It sure was a trap usually implies that we're gonna die so are we gonna die I mean?
These archways look kind of foreboding so probably no no just to McDonald's around the corner. Don't worry about it right, okay?
I wasn't gonna think of anything Hey who door got a wop with a stick
That's like my main concern the weird Smeagol ease on the wall. I've never seen the weird Smeagol ease on the wall, so we will
Minutes already okay should we start running that is I don't know dead end no wait. No what is that that's different?
I think it's still a dead end. I think it's just a creamy whatever with my stick
nope, okay, it's
Rocks Oh
Was that you or me the statues could kill you oh, I didn't see the statue I didn't either
I just heard it fall, and I'm they can kill me I
Don't know dead-end desert actually a way to go. Yeah, I think so this is one more so
Alright alright
Okay, man, I'm hearing some weird noises, Oh statue
Okay you run towards it you go
Hey, no, okay, it's a fakie alright, I don't know if it's a fakie. I think he's just sleeping
With rocks don't wanna hit up
Don't antagonize the statues! what if he was just being nice and being like, ohh, I'm not gonna murder TODAYYYYY...
I don't buy that for one second that looks like a dead end oh god
I hear something  Mark: WHAT Wade: I don't know I think it's one of the Smeagly's. I don't see it.
Mark: Can you... Can you be... descriptive?
Wade: Right here, over to the side. Mark: Can I WhAPp it with a stick?
Wade: Yeah, I think it's on the other side of the wall. Mark: Alright. Okay. I'll trust you on that one
Mark: *Unintelligible mumbling* Wade: Alright, this has been a very mostly linear path (Very mostly?)
Mark (in terror and alerted): WOAH... WOAH x5          Wade (background):  What? x2
I heard that!
I heard a skitter-scatter!
Ohh, that's not good.
How am I gonna hit something if I can't see it? I have to... Woo. I hear tha... You hear that?
(Chaos erupting) WOAH WHACK IT WHAPP IT AGHH WHAPWHAP I'M WHAPPING I
Okay I whapped it good!
Alright, maybe you should have my first boner. Yes, oh
It sure is a reverse boner
I think a reverse boner is a vagina sir
Chica I can't right now, she's nuzzling my arm - this is very disturbing
I don't think that's true. I think she's gotta go potty. We'll go in a second, OK?
Wait just a little bit just a little bit pup... ooh oOh We got a wall guy
Okay
Okay, let's not go that way if we can avoid it... Wade: Oh.
Oh, I went this way.
Why'd you go that way (It's not... dead end) Wait, Wade, where did you go I have no, oh my god hey don't don't
Activate that guy I didn't I didn't he okay good
He should have looked at me, but he didn't. :)  He didn't. He was very bad guard over there
You're just too sneaky for him. How are we gonna? We've only got like four minutes, how're we gonna do this
I don't know. Okay. What is this? OOH. th-. Um these archways look relatively important, right?
Is this the exit?!? I don't know, is it? No. That's a bridge. DEAD END! The exit has like a round
Started fucking we found every single dead-end every possible dead end
Hey, okay, I got you you argue walk Hey come into my warp zone walk town USA where WAMP WAMP
Oh, you fell backwards this time dick
Don't look don't look at its vagina. Doll. I didn't wait wait. I think I see this I think I see
Okay, look at that anymore. My son is squishy my walk. I don't know SATs are saying. There's so many screw shoes
I'm just kind of gonna like sprint towards anything because who died this ooh. Oh
It's a wall guy, I don't know I was so scared
But I just didn't know where he was looking so I miss pretender. Well you go with such confidence
I just I don't know when to go
All right it moves
Okay, I'm gonna go under I'm going under move
Okay, I did it nice. I heard something scary-sounding
Found a single lever well, you know sometimes you just got to blame yourself. You know a dead end okay?
and I blame you or maybe at the last second, we're gonna find everything all at once and that's
That statue yeah, I'm not a good statue. I would stay away from that one. No it's fine
It's at that point where the statues are gonna chases
This isn't a dead end yet hated it in what what do we work with it's impossible I?
Don't know
It's patently impossible how does any for your method oh?
I
Don't think it's one guy's
guy guys guys I don't think it's one
guys
My personalities at once no that was a dead end over there - I
Don't know no this way can go left oh
Yeah, then you didn't mark it stupid
We've run out of time for me to stay here
Alright wait, what does nothing happen if it sees you. I think it draws in nearby monsters, okay, wait
There's like kind of like a butt. Whoa a butt split
Are you we don't have any time wait? No it's the same never mind. It's all the same
Something Oh witch wizard what do I do? There's a lever hang on okay? He's gonna come after us
Okay, I'll go get it. Did you die yeah? Why did you know?
Do we win I can't run I can't I'm dead I'm so dead. Uh. I'm not very dead excuse me
He's just putting me under his robe of the
Strategy I think for those is one person has to like lower the guy way yeah
Then the other one goes for the lever and the person floors away is probably gonna die
Great if that person could be raised after the guys locks away
Okay
So how would you do that on a single player? I don't know all right?
Let's let's go again, then when at first you don't succeed
succeed
Harder. I'll do flashlight. Chalk you do all the throwy rolls. Let's roll, baby
Let's roll all right. You're leading the way, but you're also in the back to fin what?
You don't know what?
This is - going right off the bat, I get a nice red shirt
Thank you. It's from the monsters well
Also, is it's what the people on Star Trek wore when they were like sent down to the planet to die. That's true
We've bet we are dead don't you know that's all they did
Yes, that's very dead. This looks like a dead end
We don't even need to come back this way it
Oh, there's a dude right there where where the wizard guys right in front. Whoa? Hi buddy, okay?
I'll distract him. Oh never mind all right all distract me
Okay
Why does he okay wait? No just I'm gonna distract him on run through the tunnel okay here here come for me, okay?
He's coming for me. Okay, all right i'ma run through the tunnel
Yeah, that's right. That's right come on come on buddy. Okay go for it. No never mind. He's going for you now
Keep running after you get
Okay, good. Good. Good. Good. Good. Good. I don't know if he has a range of losing yeah
Oh, yeah, he does. He lost yeah, okay, okay? I'm coming. I'm coming. I'm coming. I'm coming. I'm coming
Okay, keep going keep going keep going. Oh, this isn't a dead end I got distracted with the rocks yes
Your son get rid of them you were such a champion all right. Where'd you go? Did you go back? Okay coming around okay?
Go back. This is all dead ends. Yeah, no yes
This is a dead end here that guy is still wandering trying to find us okay
But that's fine cuz that bodes well got a letter yeah
We got a lover whoa whoa okay? Well there's the same guy here. We can run
That's the way we have to go I think
Okay, every everything else is
Did we maybe I don't remember I don't think we've been this way I'm one left
Okay, Oh behind it stick guy stick. Okay? Oh
Stick him stick him. Oh, no. Oh good. Yeah. No we been here this is dead ends
We have to go down that way that the wizard is
What this way no, that's where we came from yeah, I prom you're right you're right you're right, okay, okay, okay, okay go?
This looks dead end
This is very dead end
But this is a dead end we're in trouble. Oh it looked dead end oh crap
Yeah, it's dead end we're I'm telling I'm telling you where that wizard came down
I pretty sure I'm pretty
Sure, it's either where we came from or there was another way to go past that wizard anyway, so this way he was yeah
There's a dude on the wall up bad. You see him creepy. Yeah, I saw him. I think we can avoid him
I think straight looks like a dead end yeah definitely
Not dead ends here get in no. It's wait where yeah
But the guys on the wall, but we can wipe him
Come on. Where is he oh? He's - yeah? He left. He's also running away. Okay. Dead end dead end okay
These are two dead ends no left is where we came from Oh Shadow Man Shadow Man. Whoa light get
lighted a
Light of light light oh, he's gone. Whoa whoa whoa well had you behind your body? Oh god? He's so he's so fast on you
Whoa?
He is fast yeah
Whoa what the hell? I'm trying to track him is he gone right right all right? What does the flashlight?
Do it kills them eventually okay? Well oh?
Okay, okay. I'll focus on this guy I
Think he know
All right
That's where we came from though, I think maybe baby was it yeah, that was definitely we got to go to the lead oh oh
It's all right I'll lure her away. I think she's pretty this rocks
Come on. Oh
crap
It's all good. It's all good man because she's crying again. Okay. Yeah, yeah, that's right keep going
Yeah, keep going that way all right all right all right?
Okay, we're good three minutes oof oof. It's been a doozy
Huh it has there's another dude over there
Okay, I'll go this way okay
I'll go this way looks like this is a dead end wait for this guy to change his vision before I go
This is definitely dead end
Okay, this Way's got stuff two pads here. I'm going to check left so once you get past the dude. I went left all
Right okay, three minutes
Oh, yeah, miss unmarked. Yeah, we found one lover right away. Oh yeah hopeful
Yeah, well this game doesn't seem to be one about hope
No, it does not. We've hadded quite the plethora of enemies - oh guy on the ground yeah, Charlie
You will get wept is how you get whacked?
Wow
There he goes. I'm gonna check to the right all right. I'm checking left
two paths dead end
dead end and dead end on both dead ends both dead ends on mine -
Okay, so we need to go
World's can we go I don't know I've been trying to mark, but I haven't gotten everything he's dead
I don't know if we've been either of these ways yeah, I'll go the other way wait this one looks dead indeed
Yeah, wait that in
Thought no no yeah
One you're wait
Whoa this whoa whoa there's a lady at a shadow guy there are so many enemies right right?
Here is a thing. Okay. You came behind
Well I'm getting him oh wow he died quick ladies leaving another shadow guy another one the hell
Wizard same was Rober wizard. Where'd he come from I don't know he's dead already. What the hell all right well
I've been hurt. I'm gonna run for it. I guess yeah keep running. He must have been guarding the other leper, though
He must have been tricked by the leper way. I'm a ring around this rosy
Was he was there like could there be a level in
In that no I wouldn't think so, maybe let's know
It might be the same wizard. I would not be surprised all right. Well. I'm boned. I'm boned. I'm bone. I can't run
I'm out of stamina. I'm dead well. Oh
That's so hard. It. Is how would you? How would you be able to do that?
Good God
Look, it's the know-how you can never have enough time. Yeah, it's gotta. Be look. We're just luck. Oh well
We tried we found a few lovers. We killed a few Ben amis and then we got rekt. Yeah, get killed ourselves
Maybe we're the enemy wherever were the enemy invading this land. That's true
We are just kind of like breaking into some one castle haunted house. Yeah, oh well anyway
Thanks for joining me and thank you everybody for watching and as always we will see you in the next video
Buh-Bye!